bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux alors aujourd'hui on a du pain
sur la planche parce qu'il ya un nouvel
article sur spinosaurus qui vient de
sortir sur la biologie de spinosaurus
qui remet en question le mode de vie
aquatique de l'animal donc j'aimerais
bien passer du temps sur cet article
donc je vais passer très vite sur tout
le reste mais vous retrouverez tous les
liens vers ses articles dans la
description si vous souhaitez les lire
et en savoir plus
on commence par la découverte des plus
anciennes peintures rupestres jamais
découverte
ses peintures rupestres vienne d'ado
naisy de sulawesi plus précisément voici
à quoi elle ressemble donc vous avez ici
magnifiques peintures d'un cochon
d'ailleurs c'est quasiment que des
cochons qui sont représentés en réalité
donc ses peintures elles ont été datés
grâce à la série de l'uranium
donc la série isotopique de l'uranium
uranium thorium thorium thorium etc
c'est ce que vous voyez dans ce tableau
ici et les plus récentes sont vieille
d'à peu près 30 mille ans voire même 25
mille ans et les plus anciennes sont à
peu près vieille de quarante cinq mille
ans dont quarante cinq mille ans et pour
vous donner un ordre d'idée les plus
vieilles peintures européennes elles
sont en france elles ont trente sept
mille ans lascaux ça n'a que quinze
mille ans et les plus vieilles peintures
rupestres en afrique elles ont que onze
mille ans si je ne m'abuse donc c'est
vraiment les plus anciennes peintures
pariétales connus au monde
en indonésie ce qui est quand même très
très loin du berceau de l'humanité
africain ceci dit les plus anciennes
traces d'art en afrique
elle remonte à 80 mille ans elles
viennent de la grotte de blombos ce en
afrique du sud donc ça ne remet pas
quand même en question l'origine d'homo
sapiens en afrique mais juste l'origine
de l'art pariétal qui est semblerait ce
qui semblerait être en fait un art qu'on
retrouve en dehors de l'afrique mais pas
tellement en afrique en tout cas pas
avant onze mille ans on continue avec
cet article qui nous décrit à nouveau
dinosaure français dinosaures français
qui nous vient du sud de la france 2
vélo la bastide neuve et qui s'appelle
garriga titan garriga titans qui tient
son nom de la garrigue
il s'agit d'un grand sauropode donc les
dinosaures à long cou et la petite tête
et on a ici donc on n'a pas vraiment un
squelette complet on a surtout des
restes qui sont situées autour du bassin
si je ne m'abuse
vous avez ici une vertèbre et le bassin
et figurer un petit peu plus loin voilà
ça c'est le bassin en vue d'une souhait
la de bassin en vue du dessus et vous
avez quelques os des membres qui ont été
décrits donc voilà c'est un nouveau
dinosaure français c'est pas tout c'est
pas tous les jours que ça sort donc ça
mérite qu'on en parle et évidemment
décrit par une équipe principalement
françaises surtout des chercheurs de
poitiers vous avez pascal godefroy aussi
qui nous vient de belgique
on continue avec les dinosaures à long
cou donc les titanosaures l'étude ont
garé gatti temps fait partie garriga
titan est un titanosaures sauf que là
c'est les titanosaures sud-américain
évidemment les quand vous pensez
titanosaures sud-américain vous pensez
patagonie temps vous pensez
argentinosaurus bref vous pensez
dinosaures géants et justement vous avez
certainement vu dans les news passer des
revues de presse qui parlait d'un
nouveau dinosaure géant peut être le
plus grand dinosaure jamais découvert et
bien c'est lui c'est celui là il n'a pas
de nom parce qu'ils n'ont ils n'ont pas
osé en faire une nouvelle espèce parce
qu'apparemment les restes sont vraiment
trop fragmentaires donc ils ont un bon
bout de bassins et de que apparemment
mais pour eux ça suffit pas pour faire
un une nouvelle espèce
alors ça doit vraiment être très très
mal préservé pour ne pas avoir pris pour
avoir pris la décision de pas en faire
une nouvelle espèce et donc quand on
vous dit qu'il s'agirait éventuellement
du plus grand dinosaure du monde eh bien
si rappelez-vous de la vidéo quand on
vous parlait justement de comment on
estime la taille des dinosaures
il y avait quatre grandes méthodes et
l'une d'entre elles c'était le pifomètre
et ben ça c'est typiquement un cas de
pif omettre puisqu'ils n'ont fait aucun
calcul pour estimer la taille de cet
animal que ce sont ceux que ce soit son
poids ou sa longueur c'est vraiment
juste voilà les hausses au très gros son
plus gros apparemment que ceux
d'argentine aux eaux russes ou deux fois
que les eaux correspondant
chez argentinosaurus et pata gotti temps
donc ça devrait être un animal plus gros
seins
mais bon ça reste quand même assez
pifométrique donc on attend qu'il trouve
de plus de plus amples fossiles de moi
peut-être pas de plus ample mais en tout
cas des restes plus complet pour que
enfin on en sache plus sur ce nouvel
animal on continue avec la description
alors vous voyez les articles sont
bizarrement mis en page ces normes
enfin au moins au moins ces deux là et
puis celui qui va suivre aussi les
articles sont un peu bizarrement mis en
page c'est parce que c'est encore des
sont encore à l'état de proof
ils n'ont pas encore été publiés
publiées mais par contre ils sont ils
sont accessibles en ligne
ils sont accessibles en ligne dans
l'état où ils étaient quand ils ont été
soumis par les auteurs donc ça veut pas
dire qu'ils n'ont pas été payés review
fait ils ont déjà été privés mais ils
sont encore mis en page
voilà donc on continue avec la
description des premiers bébés
tyrannosaure les bébés vraiment tout
frais sorti de l'oeuf ce qu'on appelle
des perrine des ambassades et des
spécimens périnataux des spécimens qui
viennent juste de naître
donc voici s'est pas beaucoup de
matériel je veux dire c'est juste une
griffe là vous avez aussi dans une
petite danse si je ne m'abuse
et vous avez surtout deux petites
mâchoire voilà très mignonne petite
mâchoire vous pouvez voir ici l'échelle
5 mm donc là vous avez une mâchoire qui
fait même pas 2 cm donc deux centimètres
de mâchoire pour un tyrannosaure s'est
pas beaucoup beaucoup c'est pas grand
chose donc c'est vraiment le plus petits
spécimens de tyrannosaure qu'on n'ait
jamais trouvé c'est possiblement du das
plateau aux russes c'est pas du
tyrannosaurus rex par contre je vous
arrête tout de suite c'est tyrannosaure
dans le sens famille pas dans le sens
tyrannosaurus rex donc ça c'est
probablement das plateau aux russes et
ça vous donne un animal qui était à
peine plus gros qu'un qu'un gros chat
voilà mais c'est quand même plutôt sympa
et là on voit là la comparaison de
taille surtout par rapport aux autres
spécimens de juvéniles de tyrannosaure
qu'on avait jusqu'à présent
et voilà le jusqu'à présent ça c'était
le plus petit juvénile qu'on connaissait
et voici la mâchoire de c
et de ces nouveaux petits d'aspe trésor
la voilà c'est vraiment
significativement plus petit voilà on en
sait maintenant un peu plus sur comment
tyrannosaure grandissait on continue
dans les bébés dinosaures avec la
première découverte d'un bébé ovi raptor
dans un oeuf lui-même couvé par à novi
raptor adultes dont c'est la première
fois qu'on trouve un embryon dans un
oeuf dans un fossile qui est lui-même
couvert par un adulte
ovi raptor donc tout ça dans le même
fossile donc c'est quand même une
découverte assez exceptionnel d'ailleurs
il n'ya pas qu'un embryon vous voyez il
y en a deux et donc cette découverte a
été étudié par des chercheurs français
en tout cas en partie par des chercheurs
français donc romain amiot et claire
père de fabrègues donc on les félicite
très fort et on passe enfin aux
spinosaurus alors je sais ça peut être
un peu frustrant de passer autant de
temps sur spinosaurus et si peu de temps
sur tout le reste mais comme je voulais
dit je vous mets les liens dans la
description vous pourrez aller lire les
articles vous même et évidemment
n'hésitez pas à poser des questions dans
les commentaires
cela va de soi alors spinosaurus un
nouvel article qui vient de sortir sur
la biologie de spinosaurus par david
honnête au mas auld qui sont pas les
derniers des couillons quand il s'agit
de paléontologie surtout thomas ce pôle
c'est un grand spécialiste des
théropodes si je ne m'abuse
donc voilà c'est quand même du grand nom
de la paléontologie qu'ici mais qui
publie dans paléontologie à électronique
à un article qui remet en question les
conclusions de nizar ibrahim de 2014 et
2020 sur l'écologie de spinosaurus et
notamment sur son adaptation au milieu
aquatique donc un article qui était on
va dire très attendue par les
détracteurs de nizar ibrahim et qui a
été de fait de ce fait accueilli très
chaleureusement
je pense que les gens qui ont accueilli
cet article chaleureusement ne l'ont pas
lu c'est pour ça que je vais y passer du
temps parce que quand on le lit cet
article c'est le festival de la mauvaise
foi c'est le
c'est le gros festivals surtout du biais
de confirmation c'est à dire que les
gens qui ont repartager cet article qui
ont encensé cet article à mon avis ne
l'ont pas lu ou sont victimes d'un
énorme biais de confirmation à savoir
qu'ils avaient tellement envie
d'entendre dire que ibrahim se
trompaient que voilà ça pour eux c'est
tellement évident qu'ils braillent m'a
dit de la merde que l'europe voilà on re
partage pas ce que c'est normal c'est
ont du mal ni brahim alors avec toute la
haine que j'ai pour la façon de faire
d'ibrahim notamment de faire de la
communication et de faire de la
paléontologie bling bling à l'américaine
avec toute la colère que cela suscite en
moi à chaque fois de voir un article sur
spinosaurus ou de voir même une nouvelle
reconstruction paléo artistique de
spinosaurus qui a l'originalité
franchement je peux pas dire que si ce
que vous cherchez c'est des bons
arguments réfutant l'épreuve d'ibrahim
c'est pas ici que vous les trouverez
nizar ibrahim il a fait cette hypothèse
qui est spinosaurus il était
probablement fortement aquatique voire
même plus aquatiques que terrestres donc
à la manière un peu des crocodiles c'est
l'hypothèse d'ibrahim sy vous qui vous
vous attendez à voir des preuves
réfutant cette hypothèse dans cet
article passez votre chemin
c'est pas ici que vous les trouverez
c'est pas le genre de la maison
non ici ça va être le festival de la
mauvaise foi je parle de l'article je
parle pas de moi ceci dit je vais je
vais aussi faire preuve de pas mal de
mauvaise foi mais juste autant de
mauvaise foi qui en a dans l'article en
réalité donc voilà donc cesser leur du
gros sel
j'ai envie de dire préparer le préparer
la baleine c'est l'heure du gros sel
alors avant de commencer cette critique
je devrais peut-être surtout vous dire
où je me situe par rapport à l'écologie
de spinosaures c'est à dire qu'est ce
que moi j'en pense ce que moi j'en pense
c'est que je suis pas convaincu de la
plupart des choses qu'on dit sur
spinosaures ne convainc pas c'est à dire
que ce soient terrestres ou aquatiques
pour être honnête donc là vous avez deux
reconstitutions de spinosaures
terrestres ou aquatiques toutes les deux
basés sur la reconstitution de nizas
ibrahim de 2020 donc est-ce que je pense
que ce spinosaurus était aquatique
ils ont de toute façon les spinosaures
idée
ils sont adaptés à un régime piscivores
pour la plupart et il est inodore en
particulier montrent certaines
adaptations en milieu aquatique que ce
soit déjà les jambes qui sont réduites
alors les jambes qui sont réduites on en
est à peu près sûr parce que c'est le
spécimen que nizar ibrahim a présenté en
gros c'est quasiment toute la moitié
arrière du squelette
donc ça commence ici et tout la moitié
arrière était trouvait alors en
articulation ou presque c'est à dire
qu'ils ont d'abord trouvé les jambes
puis ensuite la queue mais apparemment
c'était le même spécimens donc donc la
petite taille des jambes et notamment du
fémur semble être réel est un bon
indicateur du coût de la réduction des
jambes ça c'est généralement un truc
qu'on trouve chez les espèces
semi-aquatique ceci étant dit il y a
toujours quatre ou cinq vertèbres sacré
c'est à dire 4 ou 5 point d'attachement
entre le bassin est la colonne
vertébrale ce qui indique qu'il était
tout à fait capable de bouger sur terre
je suis plus ou moins convaincus que la
queue était pouvait être utilisé comme
moyen de propulsion non pas parce que
ils ont fait un petit modèle pour faire
plaisir à national geographic le petit
reconstruction leur eau plastoc bizarre
qui faisait tac tac tac tac tac dans
l'eau enfin tu as tendance à ça ça m'a
pas convaincu par contre le fait que
vous avez fait très plaisir à national
geographic ça fait semblant qu'on fait
de la science mais moi ce qui m'a
convaincu c'est que là où la plupart des
théropodes ont là que rigide spinosaures
lui il a des articulations de la queue
qui ne sont pas rigide et donc il
pouvait battre de la queue et
honnêtement je vois pas c'est vrai que à
part pour battre de la queue dans l'eau
je vois pas pourquoi il aurait ce à quoi
même si on part de l'hypothèse que la
queue servait de
de moyens de séduction pendant les
parades
ce qui est aussi possible à ce qui
n'exclut pas qu'il ait été aquatique
d'ailleurs mais c'est aussi possible
les basilic par exemple il se déplace
très bien dans l'eau avec leur queue qui
est tout à fait similaire à celle qu'on
voit sur spinosaures ici donc donc c'est
possible qu'il ait utilisé ça pour pour
la parade nuptiale
en tout cas chez les mâles mais ça
n'explique pas pourquoi c'est juste une
utilisation uniquement pour la parade
nuptiale n'expliquerait pas pourquoi
tant de flexibilité dans la queue en
tout cas pas tout seul ensuite la forme
de la crète la forme de la crête qui n'a
pas grand chose à voir avec le milieu
aquatique pour être tout à fait honnête
mais la forme de la cre est un peu carré
comme ça j'attends de voir plus de
squelettes parce que comme je les dis le
meut le nouveau squelette 10 à denise à
ibrahim sarr est à peu près ici donc il
ya que les deux il ya que ces deux
épines là je crois qu'ils sont préservés
les autres on les a pas vraiment ça a
été reconstitué à partir d'autres
éléments d'autres squelettes
donc c'est un composite c'est à partir
d'un composite qu'ils ont reconstitué
cette forme de crête l'a donc j'attends
de voir ce qui fait beaucoup débat aussi
c est ce qu il était quadruple double
peine là ils sont partis sur une posture
bipèdes mais apparemment d'après nizar
ibrahim encore une fois les bras aurait
été très gros par rapport aux jambes bon
comme il s'agit pas des bras qui
appartiennent aux spécimens auquel
appartenaient les jambes
voilà ça vous pouvez le laisser de côté
bien comme il faut vous pouvez vous le
ranger dans un coin à mon avis ça
tiendra pas le jour où on va découvrir
un spécimen complet
à mon avis ça tiendra plus les
spinosaures idées comme tous les
théropodes étaient par défaut par défaut
bipèdes
donc même si les jambes étaient
relativement courtes ça m'étonnerait
qu'ils aient pu se déplacer sur les bras
et on voit aucune adaptation des
phalanges si je si je me rappelle bien
il ya aucune réelle adaptation des
phalanges pour marcher sur les phalanges
donc fin des phalanges des mains
évidemment donc ça m'étonnerait ça ça ça
m'étonnerait que ça résistera à la
découverte d'un d'inde à spinosaures
complet avait-il des pieds palmés c'est
du tissu mou on ne saura jamais voilà ça
vous pouvez
le car est son bras et vous devrez
dormir avec parce que j'admire ceux qui
disent qu'ils n'avaient pas les pieds
palmés ceux qui disent qu'ils avaient
les pieds palmés ils ont tous les deux
fois on saura jamais voilà ça c'est
clair c'est fini je veux dire dans
l'absolu dans l'absolu j'ai même envie
de dire que la crête
même si c'est une hypothèse très
raisonnable de dire qu'elle était
couverte de chair on en a aucune idée
le seul moyen de prouver que cette crête
était couverte de chair c'est soit un de
trouver un spécimen tellement bien
préservé que les tissus mous sont
préservés bon c'est pas impossible mais
ça m'étonnerait que ça arrivera pour
spinosaurus égyptiens cus ou deux comme
celle du métro dont de trouver une crête
dont qui a été cassé et qui sert
cicatriser mais tout les morceaux de la
crête se sont cicatrisées exactement de
la même façon ce qui montre qu'ils
étaient attachés les uns aux autres des
épines dorsales qui ne sont pas reliés
par une crête voulait péter ben il y en
a qui vont tomber il y en a qui vont se
plier dans l'autre sens y en a qui vont
au bref ils vont par cicatriser tous
exactement dans la même position alors
que s'ils sont reliés par une membrane
alors là vous les p t il tombe d'un côté
ils restent ensemble et ils se re cité
cicatrise ensemble ça ça a été montré
pour 10 métro dont ce qui démontre qu'il
avait une crête
mais pour spinosaures ça n'a pas été
démontrée mais bon ça reste une
hypothèse raisonnable évidemment donc il
avait au moins une crête voire même
certains disent une bosse de grèce
pourquoi pas et à quoi servait cette
crête on n'en sait rien et pareil on ne
sera probablement jamais certains disent
thermorégulation ça m'étonnerait puisque
maintenant on sait plus ou moins admis
que les dinosaures étaient des des andes
au terme surtout les théropodes en tout
cas donc c'est plus ou moins admis que
les théropodes étaient en d'autres
termes donc thermorégulation peux te
probablement pas encore une fois
pour la parade nuptiale c'est pas
impossible camouflage reconnaissance
intraspécifique sont d'autres
possibilités et comme je le j'assiste là
dessus mais on ne le saura jamais voilà
on aura peut-être des hypothèses plus
raisonnable que d'autres mais pour
l'instant ça reste tout ça ça reste des
hypothèse probable
j'ai ma petite faveur pour l'utilisation
l'utilisation en parades sexuelles tout
de même mais c'est mon petit préféré
j'ai pas forcément de raison objective
de le préférer un poids tout à fait
honnête spinosaures aussi des crêtes sur
la tête ça par contre ça peut être que
un truc ça ça peut être que un truc soit
de reconnaissance interspécifique soit
de reconnaissance intraspécifique et
dans ce cas-là de reconnaissance des
mâles entre eux pour ce faire pour se
bouffer la tronche en période de
reproduction
donc voilà où je m'en tiens sur les
différentes hypothèses concernant
spinosaurus je suis pas particulièrement
amoureux des hypothèses de nizar ibrahim
et je suis pas particulièrement contre
les hypothèses qui l'a proposée non plus
c'est juste qu'il y en a certaines qui
sont est stable et il y en a certaines
on n'aura jamais de réponse
un point c'est tout donc si vous n'avez
pas envie de passer trop longtemps sur
cette vidéo
parce que cette vidéo risque d'être
longue sachez que le plus gros problème
de l'article vraiment le truc qui va
être le fil conducteur de cette critique
tout le long c'est quelque chose qui se
trouve directement dans l'intro donc dès
l'introduction les auteurs nous annonce
la couleur
ils vont opposer ce qu'ils appellent le
wedding modèle aux poursuites prédateurs
modèle alors qu'est ce que c'est que ça
c'est tout simplement ils vont opposer
la reconstitution du spinosaures qui se
tient debout dans la flotte avec le nez
dans l'eau pour attraper les pour
attraper les poissons qui passe sous son
nez donc un modèle de spinosaures un
petit peu à la façon d'une cigogne ou
quoi ou d'un héros voilà plutôt d'un
héros là dedans ils font une comparaison
plutôt avec le marabout plutôt que le
héron ont plus africain voilà mais bref
donc vous avez le modèle héron le
wedding modèle je vous mettrais une
petite image et vous avez évidemment le
modèle
super aquatique de spinosaures ce qu'il
appelle le post pour ce prédateur modèle
alors qu'est ce qui se cache derrière la
définition de ces deux modèles ba déjà
il se cache un faux dilemme se cache un
faux dilemme ça voudrait dire qu'en gros
le spinosaures soit il se comportait
comme un héros soit il se comportait
comme un comme un animal aquatique
or on a on à bâle de bestioles qui se
comportent qui peuvent chasser
ponctuellement en se perchant sur le
bord de l'eau puis aller nager je veux
dire c'est pas laissez pas les oiseaux
aquatiques qui manquent notamment que
juste pour prendre des exemples de
dinosaure un des oiseaux aquatiques qui
al'occasion picorer dans l'eau ou qui
vont carrément plongé aller nager
c'est comme avec le tyrannosaure le faux
dilemme entre carnivores prédateurs et
carnivores charognards forcément les
charognards ils vont pas cracher sur un
petit lapin s'il leur passe sous le nez
et forcément les prédateurs vont pas
cracher sur une belle carcasse bien
fraîche il ya le récit à leur est servi
sur un plateau ou quoi donc voilà
typiquement les lions et les hyènes sont
l'exemple les exemples les plus reconnus
donc si vous aimez la zététique vous
allez kiffer cet article parce qu'il ya
vraiment quasiment tous les exemples de
billets de confirmation de tous les to
les sophismes tous les sophismes
classique mais dans un article qui a été
accepté dans un journal peer review donc
tous les grands sophisme classiques sont
là le premier c'est ce faux dilemme le
faux dilemme entre le modèle est rond et
le modèle nageurs spinosaures n'aurait
pas le droit d'être moitié la moitié
l'autre ils n'auraient pas le droit
d'être
d'être autre chose pourquoi pas il n'y a
aucune autre hypothèse qui est envisagée
non c'est vraiment l'un ou l'autre
notamment l'hypothèse spinosaures était
complètement terrestre alors celle là
par contre elle est complètement oublié
ceci dit à les oublier a raison mais bon
ça aurait été bien de l'évaluer quand
même même rapidement au début quoi je
veux dire il ya quand même eu une époque
où on pense explosant était complètement
terrestres et en plus on va avoir le
droit à un homme de paille l'homme de
paille qu'est ce que c'est c'est quand
vous proposer quand vous avez
l'hypothèse que vous vous proposez et
qu'en face vous y opposer une hypothèse
qui est caricaturalement nul à chier
voilà pour dire les choses simplement
donc vous avez votre hypothèse à vous
qui brigue qui est shiny comme ça qui
est qu'il solide et en face vous
proposer une hypothèse l'hypothèse de
vos ennemis l'hypothèse de nizar ibrahim
le redoutable nizar ibrahim le terrible
qui lui a une hypothèse tout cas qu'à et
comment vous pouvez croire ça c'est tout
pourri telle hypothèse
et ben voilà là on est face à ce cas là
donc le modèle de la poursuite
donc le modèle soit disant défendu par
nizar ibrahim
il est défini comment il est défini donc
sur la base d'une citation de nizar
ibrahim donc citation de son article de
2020 spinosaures selon nizar ibrahim
donc c'est une citation était après
d'acteurs actif et très spécialisés au
milieu était à prédateurs aquatiques
actifs et spécialisés qui poursuivait
attraper ses proies dans le colonnes
d'eau c'est l'hypothèse de nizar ibrahim
de 2020 je ne conteste pas ça par contre
il va passer en face cet article va
passer à une quantité incroyable de
temps a insisté sur le terme poursuites
d'où le terme tout pursuit prédateurs
modèle ce mot la poursuite il va hanter
l'article mais tout le long c'est à dire
que dès qu'il va trouver un argument
pour dire que spinosaures ne pouvait pas
nager aussi vite qu'à poisson en gros
pour lui ça va être un contre argument
du modèle dit brahim ibrahim je pense
pas qu'il ait voulu être aussi
spécifique que ça je pense qu'il a juste
voulu dire que spinosaures et est
aquatique avec tout ce que ça implique
de vagues autour en fin de
vague la blague donc tout ce que ça
implique de vagues autour de la
définition d'aquatique ce voilà
aquatique au sens très large
je pense que c'est ça qu'il a voulu dire
une izzat ibrahim il n'a pas voulu dire
spécifiquement un prédateur qui pouvait
se nourrir que en attrapant du poisson
en plein vol et c'est tout et bein euh
c'est ça qu'ils disent que nizar
ibrahima 10 et si ça peut pas attraper
du poisson en plein vol comme ça à la
volée ça veut dire qu'ils braillent me
l'a dit de la merde et à côté de ça vous
avez le wedding modèle qui est défini en
groupe comme étant spinosaures semi
aquatique au sens très large
c est donc ceci donc ce qu'il aime
décrire au dessus peut être décrit comme
semi aquatique
car ce terme recouvre une très grande
quantité de comportement et de degré
d'adaptation au milieu aquatique
pour résumer ces animaux se comportent
comme des héros ou des grues
il capture du poisson et d'autres prêts
aquatique depuis les bords de l'eau ou
les eaux peu profondes mais ils peuvent
aussi aller chercher des points sur la
terre ferme et voire même être des
charognards donc là en gros dans la
définition du wedding modèle dans la
définition du modèle et on vous pouvait
être semi aquatique au sens large voire
même aller chercher des points sur la
terre ferme
donc ça veut dire qu'en gros vous
opposer le modèle où le spinosaures
c'était un dauphin voilà nizar ibrahim a
dit le spinosaures c'était un dauphin à
un modèle où le spinosaures il pouvait
être aussi semi-aquatique qu un héron ou
qu'un crocodile ou qu une otarie enfin
bref vous vous recouvrez à peu près tout
le spectre de semis aquatis mme
possibles allant de patauge une fois de
temps en temps a passé sa vie dans l'eau
mais rod est encore capable de retourner
sur terre
est ce que vous le sentez la l'homme de
paille est ce que vous le sentez quand
gros vous avez le modèle indémontrable
parce qu'il est trop excessivement
étroits trop excessivement spécifiques
et le modèle qui autorise tellement de
degrés de liberté que de toute façon
quoique vous dit
et êtes à peu près sûr que ça tombera
dedans voilà donc vous avez un modèle
très spécifiques contre un modèle
extrêmement vagues et qui recouvre une
quantité de type écologique absolument
gigantesque ah voilà charognards
terrestre semi aquatique
donc en gros au final de ce qu'on va
avoir c'est ça ça va être tout du long
de l'article
une démonstration que spinosaures va
mieux avec ce modèle là le modèle héron
qu'avec le modèle aquatique strictes sur
la base que en gros pour être aquatique
strict il faut pouvoir attraper des
poissons comme ça à la volée faut
pouvoir attraper des poissons pourraient
être aussi rapide qu'un poisson il faut
être un dauphin voilà pour pouvoir être
aquatique
il faut être un dauphin je veux dire ça
vous ça sent la mauvaise foi d'une comme
je le disais c'est hyper de mauvaise foi
c'est complètement un faux dilemme je
veux dire il n'y a pas de il n'existe
pas de modèle où vous êtes soins et
reçoit un dauphin soit rien du tout et
pour combler le vide bas tout ce qui
n'est pas un dauphin en gros ce sera
considéré comme un héros homme de paille
voilà et donc au final eh ben vous avez
un article qui va forcément conclure
basé sur ces prémisses la l'article ne
peut que conclure que spinosaures était
seulement semi aquatique est pas
complètement aquatique c'est pas
possible de terminer cet article
autrement l'hypothèse de base est
irréfutable et c'est ce qu'on va voir à
la fin je vais vous montrer le il il le
dit même clairement à la fin que de
toute façon il n'y a aucun moyen de
prouver que ce modèle là puisse exister
tout court freddy archers spinosaures à
dire à partir du moment où spinosaures à
quatre pattes de toute façon c'est pas
un dauphin donc on peut immédiatement
abandonner ce modèle là quoi c'est tout
mais bon ça laisse quand même un certain
d'un énorme degré de liberté comme je
les dis depuis le héron jusqu'à notari
en passant par le crocodile et les
canards ça laisse quand même un gros
paquet possibilités et on va appeler
tout ça le wedding modèle pour la
facilité alors maintenant je vais
rentrer très dans le détail alors ça
devient très technique je ne m'en
voudrez pas de laisser la vidéo
maintenant
un beau abonne toi mais la cloche toi
même tu sais tout ça tout ça pour
paraphraser les grues youtuber et puis
pour ceux qui sont qui ont envie de que
je les emmène faire un petit tour dans
le beau pays de la recherche et là c'est
parti on y va alors la méthode la
méthode elle est formidable
j'adore la méthode années merveilleuses
donc ils ont fait une analyse en
composante principale c'est une méthode
statistique qui permet de prendre plein
de mesurer dans de les mettre dans un
dans une seule figure qui n'a que deux
axes en fait donc au lieu d'avoir
quarante mille trucs à gérer en gros
vous simplifier toutes vos mesures en
deux axes c'est très compliqué mais ça
c'est très pratique aussi parce que
visuellement ça donne des choses jolies
comme ça surtout quand on met des jolies
couleurs
donc ils ont fait un protocole de
mesures qui consiste à mesurer la
hauteur du crâne la longueur du crâne
la distance entre la narine et le bord
antérieure du museau et la distance
entre l'oeil et le bord supérieur de la
tête
donc tout ça pour voir si en fait l'oeil
est situé en position dorsale comme chez
les crocodiles voilà pour regarder au
dessus de l'eau et pour savoir si la
narine est remonté vers l'arrière paraît
comme chez les crocodiles et les hippos
pour pouvoir renifler au dessus de l'eau
quand on est complètement immergé sauf
que ils admettent eux mêmes que la
longueur du crâne est un très mauvais
indicateur de la taille du corps surtout
chez les espèces qui ont un museau long
comme les crocodiles et puis les gars
vial enfin les crocodiles des gavials et
les philosophes que vous voyez ici mais
ils le gardent quand même
donc en gros ils disent que leur analyse
pca et enfin leur analyse à composante
principale on appelle ça une pca ou une
apc en français leur analyse apc envoie
les daubes et voilà et il considère que
la taille du crâne s'est approprié voilà
c'est écrit là donc on regarde pas de
souci ils vont faire aussi une analyse
sur la griffe
alors je ne sais même pas si l'on
montrait quelque part il doit y avoir
une analyse sur les griffes en figures
voilà une analyse sur les griffes sur la
courbure de la griffe dont vous voyez
ils ont mesuré cet angle-là la courbure
de la griffe est pareil la courbure de
la griffe c'est le grand festival des
approximations puisqu'il nous dise une
simple mesure de la forme de la griffe
n'est pas efficace pour quantifier la
géométrie complexe et delà de la griffe
et les comportements qui y sont associés
mais ça devrait être suffisant
déclara-t-il mais ça doit être suffisant
déclara-t-il donc en gros il ya
quelqu'un déjà qui a fait le truc avant
en 2017 chez les oiseaux qui a trouvé
aucun signal écologique
or on voit pas la différence entre les
espèces aquatiques et les espèces
terrestres
que font-ils pour voir si leurs espèces
de dinosaures étaient terrestres ou
aquatiques et bah il mesure ça alors
qu'ils savent déjà que ça a rien donné
chez les oiseaux actuels bien faisons le
quand même donc voilà donc leurs deux
analyses
parce que ces deux seules les analyses
qui vont faire pendant cet article à ces
deux seuls donc leurs deux analyses
elles sont daubé de base
alors maintenant les résultats de cette
apc qu'est ce qu'ils nous disent qu'ils
nous disent leur rien voilà où se
trouvent les spinosaures ils sont ici
voilà c'est les petits points rose
voilà où se trouvent les crocodiles
voilà où se trouvent les philosophes
bref ce graphe nous montre que
spinosaurus n'est pas un crocodile c'est
à peu près tout ce que nous dit ce
graphe
ceci étant dit je crois qu'on était au
courant par contre ce qu'il nous montre
que spinosaurus était aquatique ou non
absolument pas puisque vous voyez que
dans le petit tas de points qu'il ya ici
vous avez des reptiles terrestres et
vous avez des reptiles marins comme les
plésiosaures et vous avez des dinosaures
et vous avez un petit peu de philosophie
sylla qui déborde sur le petit tas de
points ici donc les philosophes qui
était
supposé aquatique donc qu'est-ce que ce
qu'est ce que cette apc nous dit rien
voilà ne démontrera rien et c'est à peu
près je veux dire quand on voyait le
protocole de mesure à la base je
m'attendais pas à grand chose non plus
l'analyse des l'analyse des griffes
maintenant qu'est ce qu'elle nous
raconte elle nous raconte que les
griffes de spinosaures ici en rouge sont
à peu près aussi plate que beaucoup
d'autres griffes de théropodes donc à la
limite celui qui a dit que parce que les
griffes était plate
ils avaient ils avaient les pieds palmés
effectivement il a dit une connerie mais
comme je les dis plutôt ça surprendra
personne puisque de toute façon dire que
puis spinosaures avec les pieds palmés
c'est une hypothèse qui n'est pas tes
stable voilà donc on vient de finir le
matériel méthodes et les résultats d
analyses d analyse mathématique entre
guillemets et c'est déjà pas brillant je
le dire il n'y a pas grand-chose à
conclure de ces analyses quoi clairement
il n'y a rien à dire
ce qui nous amène donc directement à la
discussion
alors dans cette discussion ils vont
prendre les caractères enfin les
structures anatomiques une par une et
nous dire en quoi ces structures
anatomiques ne sont pas celle d'un
dauphin
donc le modèle aquatiques mais sont bel
et bien celle d'un semi aquatique au
sens extrêmement large
encore une fois cachez votre surprise
donc il nous dit notamment que les
narines sont rétractés plutôt vers
l'arrière que vers le haut ce qui veut
dire que quand il était dans l'eau ce
qui nous montre avec une figure très
subtil ce qui veut dire que quand il
était dans l'eau en fête ses narines ne
devait pas sortir du lot mais
il aurait pu se noyer en fait bon là et
nous montre quand même une situation un
peu ridicule là où le spinosaures
essaierait de répit et de respirer en
mettant le bout de son museau là alors
que ses narines sont là donc ça c'est ça
démontre que dalle là bas moi je trouve
que c'est pas si mal enfin je veux dire
après tout dépend de la quantité de
viande qu'il ya ici le dire parce que
bon c'est la ccit les narines sont
situés direct un endroit où le crâne
lundi qu effectivement elles sont à peu
près sûr niveau de l'homme et enfin s'il
ya plus ou moins de viande
elle pouvait avoir moyen de sortir
évidemment ce n'est pas incompatible
avec le fameux modèle du héron ça je
suis d'accord mais bon c'est pas plus
incompatibles du coup avec le modèle
l'autre modèle qui est celui de
spinosaures aquatique du coup il nous
dit ensuite que les yeux ne sont pas
situés en position dorsale comme chez un
crocodile qui leur permet donc de
regarder au dessus de l'eau pendant
qu'ils sont immergés mais qu'ils sont au
contraire si tu es plutôt sur le côté
selon eux
alors selon eux parce qu'encore une fois
ce dont cette figure là quand même
ici vous avez l'oeil l'oeil est quand
même situé au dessus du niveau de l'eau
qu'il reconstitue donc bon hein c'est
pas très cohérent avec l'image qu'il
donne mais passons les yeux sont situés
sur les côtés de la tête donc il n'était
pas aquatique donc alors est-ce que vous
avez vu un dauphin récemment est-ce que
vous avez vu une baleine récemment ben
je vais vous en montrer donc voici une
magnifique image d'un dauphin prise au
pif sur google le dauphin n'a pas les
yeux au sommet du crâne comme un
crocodile
il a les yeux sur le côté de la tête
comme un dauphin comme un spinosaures
d'après eux d'ailleurs
donc ça ne démontre absolument rien au
contraire plus un animal va être adapté
à un milieu fortement aquatiques et moi
la position des yeux au sommet du crâne
va être important la position des yeux
au sommet du crâne sané important que si
on passe son temps à de semis semi
immergé comme un crocodile c'est à dire
quand on est semi aquatique un dauphin
il passe sa vie dans l'eau et si
spinosaurus il passé sa vie dans l'eau
bas il n'y a aucune raison pour laquelle
il aurait les yeux au sommet du crâne
et puis la position des narines rétracte
et surtout vers l'arrière épatant pas
tellement vers le haut chez spinosaures
c'est pareil chez les dauphins chez les
dauphins les narines sont rétractés
extrêmement loin vers l'art
et c'est pareil chez les lamantins les
narines sont rétractés extrêmement loin
vers l'arrière
quasiment un peu bas chez les dauphins
sa forme un évent et chez les lamantins
sa forme presque 1 et vente
en tout cas c'est sur le sommet du crâne
définitivement donc donc donc ça au lieu
de démontrer ce qu'ils croient que ça
démontre c'est à dire que spinosaures
n'était pas aquatique
ça démontre exactement l'opposé ça c'est
des arguments qu'on pourrait beaucoup
mieux utilisé pour démontrer qu
spinosaures était aquatiques que pour
dire que spinosaures ne l'était pas et
alors là il a ses mots magnifiques ces
mots grandiose
donc la position des yeux pas au sommet
du crâne suggère selon eux que
spinosaures ne passait pas son temps
habituellement submergé dans l'eau et
donc n'étaient pas un spécialiste semi
aquatiques comme le sont les philosophes
les crocodiles et aussi ce qu'on voit
chez les cétacés
parce qu'on voit chez les cétacés c'est
rigoureusement l'opposé de ce que tu
viens de décrire
alors je sais pas comment ça s'est passé
à travers le processus de review mais
cette phrase là alors je ne sais pas je
suis presque sûr que ce n'est pas ça
qu'ils ont voulu dire le dire ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils soient pas au
courant de l'anatomie des cétacés
surtout en citant ehning et mai 2009 190
med c'est quand même un écran ehning et
m'aide c'est quand même deux grands
spécialistes des cétacés donc s'ils ont
lu l'article qu'il cite ils sont au
courant un bon et puis s'ils ont déjà vu
un dauphin au moins la télé ils sont au
courant aussi donc là je sais pas
comment c'est passé à travers le
processus de review ça mais quelqu'un
aurait dû leur dire que là il y avait un
problème
donc voilà donc déjà l'argument de la
position des narines l'argument de la
position des yeux les narines
bof la position des yeux rejeté direct
ensuite il s'attaque à l'argument selon
lequel on trouverait plus de dents dans
les milieux aquatiques notamment des
calmes keim donc au maroc donc là dans
les dépôts aquatiques que sur les dépôts
terrestre de spinosaurus et il nous dit
que il y a en fait chez les spinosaures
et notamment chez spinosaurus il ya un
très fort taux de remplacement dentaire
donc en fait là où il y avait des
spinosaures on s'attend à trouver
beaucoup beaucoup de spinosaures sauf
que
et donc c'est ça qui expliquerait
pourquoi il ya autant de dents de
spinosaures dans les calmes kent on
parle de on parle de dunes dominance on
va dire des spinosaures sur tout le
reste des carnivores apparemment sauf
que si ça c'est vrai ça devrait être
vrai dans tous les milieux et pas
seulement dans le milieu aquatique et si
c'est vrai que dans le milieu aquatique
ça veut pas forcément dire que
spinosaurus était forcément aquatica
faut pas oublier tous les biais de
fossilisation qui peut y avoir tous les
billets taffonneau milk qui peut y avoir
c'est juste que justement interprété le
paléoenvironnement de cette façon c'est
là c'est la main tendue à
l'interprétation d'un billet de
fossilisation en fait donc il vaut mieux
se garder d'interpréter ce genre de
choses là et là pour le coup si on
consomme des sites vraiment de continuer
à interpréter les choses comme il le
font mais je suis désolé mais si si
vraiment le nombre de remplacements
dentaire
était un facteur important dans le
nombre de dents fossilisées à la base
chez les spinosaures idée on devrait
trouver
on devrait trouver beaucoup de dents de
spinosaures dans les milieux aquatiques
mais aussi dans les millions d'euros
aquatiques notamment dans les plaines
d'inondation
et apparemment ce n'est pas le cas donc
comment il explique sa façon et comme je
vous ai dit qu'il avait la conclusion de
l'article avant de décrire donc te
voyais tout ce qu'on a dit tout à
l'heure la le matériel méthodes pour un
génial les calculs mathématiques au
rabais et tout ça tout ça c'est motivé
par une chose assez motivé par le fait
que de toute façon avant même de penser
à écrire l'article il avait déjà la
conclusion donc tout ce qu'ils font là
c'est biais de confirmation biais de
confirmation biais de confirmation je
vais chercher je veux faire du cherry
picking
comme on dit la cueillette des cerises
la sélection d'informations pour aller
voir pour aller trouver l'information
que moi je veux et rien d'autre c'est ça
je veux l'information qui confirme que
j'ai raison et c'est exactement ça qui
font quoi alors là il ya la fameuse
image de donc du marabout donc le fameux
modèle du héros ou de la grue selon
comment selon quels articles de presse
vous avez lu parce que évidemment dans
la presse a été vendu comme spinosaures
se comportait comme un héros ou comme
une grue comme un marabout est
évidemment ce qu'ils mettent en avant
c'est la rétraction des narines qui leur
permet de man de chercher de la
nourriture tout en gardant les narines
en dehors de l'eau exactement comme on
pense comme eux pensent que faisait
spinosaurus ce qui est ce qui est vrai
je veux dire dans le cas ici présent ces
marabouts sont capables de piocher de la
nourriture dans l'eau sans se noyer
grâce à leurs narines qui sont situées à
peu près au même endroit que là où il se
trouve chez spinosaurus sauf que
il ya toujours un sauf que sauf que la
rétraction des narines c'est à caractère
général des oiseaux c'est pas un
caractère spécifique aux oiseaux semi
aquatique et encore moins aux marabouts
c'est un caractère général des oiseaux
j'en veux pour preuve ce magnifique
crâne de poules voilà encore une fois
piocher sur internet au pif la bonne
science comme on les aime voilà vous
prenez un crâne de poule ceci est le
bout du museau de la poule
ceci est la position des narines narines
qui sont donc vers l'arrière et vers le
haut c'est la position par défaut des
narines des oiseaux 1
je ne les invente pas vous le voyez
devant vous donc dire que c'est ça le
signe que voir l'adaptation magique du
wedding modèle du modèle est rond non
tous les oiseaux sont par défaut montée
comme ça donc le marabout il aurait même
enfin les hérons et tout ça il aurait
même été pas semi aquatique et il
n'aurait pas eu ce mode de chasse là il
aurait quand même eu les narines
rétracter vers l'arrière ils pointent
ici assez justement le fait que le on a
beaucoup dit à propos des museaux de
spinosaures qu'ils étaient couverts de
plein de petites ponctuation je sais pas
si on a une belle image du crâne mais en
gros le museau de ce prix nous offre ici
il ya plein de petites ponctuation il ya
plein de petits trous et que ces petits
trous en fait était possiblement des
petits trous sensoriel à l'image de ce
qu'on voit sur le crâne du crocodile et
que du coup ça nous permettait de sentir
les vibrations de l'eau et donc il
pointe assez justement que porteur et 8
meur ont dit que non tout les théropodes
avait ça tous les théropodes avait des
petits trous sur le museau et que
c'était pas spécial c'était pas
spécifique à spinosaurus c'est vrai mais
du coup du coup ça ne soutient ni le
modèle est rond puisque dans le modèle
est rond je rappelle que le bout du
museau sera immergée voilà le modèle et
on le bout du museau du museau avec ses
petits trous sensorielle sera immergée
pour sentir les poissons passé
exactement de la même façon que le bout
du museau serez immergé pour sortir les
poissons passé sur le modèle aquatique
avec ce modèle stupid love qui
sur lequel ne marche pas quoi donc là
c'est pas un argument ni pour ni contre
un pour le coup et enfin il nous
présente pour le en tout cas pour le
crâne en général il nous présente donc
le fait qu'il ya un article tout
récemment chez d'étals 2020 dans lequel
il reconstitue la posture de la tête de
irrita thor basée sur l'orientation du
canal semi-circulaires latéral donc ils
ont regardé l'oreille interne
et comme l'oreille interne c'est
l'organe de la deûle équilibre en fait
la façon de l'oreille interne est
orienté serait un bon indicateur de la
posture de la tête en général et grâce à
ça ils ont déterminé qu'en gros
spinosaures il avait plutôt la tête
orientée comme ça la plupart du temps ce
qu'on appelle la posture de la tête
habituel donc il aurait la tête
légèrement comme ça donc ils ont fait ça
sur irrite à tort puisons généralisée on
va dire aux spinosaures idées pour dire
justement que ça soutenait le modèle
chasse façon héros donc les spinosaures
idée aurait plutôt la tête orientée de
cette façon un article d'un petit gars
qu'est sorti ya pas longtemps écrit pas
un p'tit gars que vous connaissez
probablement pas qui s'appelle julien
benoît et ce julien benoît donc votre
hôte ici présents a écrit un article
justement pour dire que l'orientation de
la tête finalement elle était peut-être
pas tant déterminé que ça par l'oreille
interne par l'orientation de l'oreille
interne alors conseil là il ya une
grosse base de données il s'est un peu
fait chier à voyager à travers le monde
pour aller observer les animaux sur le
terrain pour pouvoir voir si leur
oreille interne c'est était vraiment
orienté de la façon qu'ils disent
quand la tête est en position normale
entre guillemets normal bon c'est
difficile à définir mais on vous voit la
cour au final dire que banon ce n'était
pas le cas c'est alors c'est ce qui est
montré dans cette figure la voilà vous
avez ici orientations de la tête
orientations de l'oreille interne
voilà cherchez une corrélation là dedans
ouais il a quand même essayé le mec de
travail de tracer une droite histoire
d'avoir l'air pas trop d'un charlot mais
non il n'y a pas de corrélation il ya la
corrélation est hyper hyper faible ya
une toute petite toute petite
corrélation tout petit mais non rien n'y
a pas de quoi y'a pas de quoi crier de
toute façon il ya une telle dispersion
autour de la droite de régression que
vous pouvez rien prédire
donc en gros ce que cet article veut
dire c'est que quand vous avez une
oreille interne de dinosaures comme
irrite à tort si vous voulez
reconstituer la posture de la tête de
l'animal avec ben vous avez en gros 200
% de chances de vous tromper
c'est à peu près ça l'idée vous avez à
peu près de 100% de chances de vous
planter
donc voilà c'est plus en plus on a dit
dans cet article que l'oreille de toute
façon elle n'est pas directement aligné
avec la tête donc la façon dont ils ont
reconstruit la posture de la tête pour
veritate hors de toute façon elle est
fausse j'ajoute au passage que
l'orientation de l'oreille interne
indique que la posture de la tête dit
rita tort la posture habituelle avait le
museau qui pointaient vers le bas mais
est ce que vraiment pointé le museau
vers le bas c'est vraiment un signe que
les animaux ne sont pas semi aquatique
la réponse est non la réponse est non la
preuve chez l'hippopotame l'hippopotame
voyait non seulement quand l'oreille
interne est dans la même position que
chérie tu as tort le museau pointent
vers le bas mais en plus quand vous
regardez l'animal quand ils se déplacent
sur terre sa tête pointe fortement vers
le bas et même dans l'eau elles pointent
encore légèrement vers le bas
donc c'est non c'est pas du tout un
argument pour pouvoir dire que irrite à
tort et les spinosaures idée n'était pas
semi aquatique en tout cas pas au moins
autant semi-aquatique que les
hippopotames qui se déplacent
majoritairement dans l'eau comme lisa
ibrahim en fait de l'hypothèse pour les
spinosaures banques donc bas donc non
c'est kaput
c'est kaput et ça fait un peu mal aux
sur julien benoît
voir que les gens publient des choses
comme ça après sa publication à lui
qu'ils aient fait ça avant je peux
comprendre mais après d'autant que c'est
pas c'est pas paru dans une revue
particulièrement cryptic 1 c'est parti
c'est quand même paru dans scientific
report qui est une revue géré par
nature's c'est un impact factor de 5 ce
qui pour la paléontologie et juste assez
gigantesque donc le coût de spinosaures
est relativement long d'après ce qu'ils
disent ce qui est vrai le coût de
spinosaures est relativement long or
chez les hacher les espèces aquatiques
comme les dauphins
le coup est généralement réduit donc
spinosaures n'était pas aquatique nous
distille c'est ce qu'ils disent là un
oui mais c'est oublier une certaine
quantité de proches parents de
spinosaures qui était aquatique et avait
le coulon chez les reptiles notamment
donc l'at-il au sens large sont sur
oxyde j'entends vous avez tout un tas de
bestioles semi aquatique qui ont le coup
très très long semi-aquatique voire très
aquatique qui ont le coup très très long
donc chez les semi aquatique vous avez
le signe par exemple fameux exemple de
bestioles semi aquatique avec un coût
très long et chez les bestioles
pleinement aquatique
vous avez un très grand nombre de
tortues notamment les tortues pleuraux
dire qu'ils ont un coût extrêmement long
vous avez aussi parmi les taxes ont
éteint les plésiosaures qui ont un coût
extrêmement long et était totalement
aquatique et pour le coup on n'a pas
trop de doutes qui s'étaient totalement
aquatique
vous avez tanis trophée us aussi qui
était un animal avec un coût très très
long est totalement aquatique est ce
qu'on va négliger tout ça la réponse est
oui
négligeant tout ça il n'en parle même
pas ça n'est même pas mentionné ici
donc voilà on oublie la possibilité
qu'un animal peut être complètement
aquatique et avoir le coup qu'on y perd
l'on voit la spinosaures à le coulon
donc il n'est pas pratique
fin de l'histoire fin de la discussion
on va pas y passer la nuit
passons à la que la queue avec ses
apophyses tellement longue ses épines
tellement longue qu'elle devait
supporter une membrane qui devait lui
l'aider à nager et évidemment la queue
qui était très flexible
qui aussi aurait pu l'aider à nager il
ya une critique qui me semble assez
saine du modèle de des petits jouets la
denise à ibrahim la cantine fse quand il
est fait se secouer dans l'eau je sais
plus examen en exactement où elle est
mais ils critiquent ce à un moment je
pense que c'est une critique assez juste
je l'air ce truc qu'ils ne démonteraient
à rien je trouve donc maintenant comment
il est exclu la possibilité que les
spinosaures tentera que spinosaurus est
était semi aquatique
enfin et était complètement aquatique
pardon avec cette que là bas il compare
ça à des envies raptor il compare ça à
des dry on their bref il compare ça un
peu plus loin encore avec des mots à
tort si je ne m'abuse
donc bref et il compare ça avec des
bestioles qui sont éteintes donc même si
on est pour les mozart par exemple
relativement sûr qu'ils étaient
aquatique je veux dire on est toujours
du domaine de la spéculation c'est à
dire qu'on compare des gros hypothèse à
d'autres grosses d'hypothèses pour
confirmer que la deuxième grosse
hypothèse elle est fausse dire c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche vous regardez les
espèces modernes principe d'actual isme
principe d' actualiser à la il a quand
même s'ils ont quand même cette remarque
que je trouve pertinente qui est que les
les epide neural de spinosaures sont
quand même vachement fine pour un truc
qui était censé servir à nager et ça ça
je suis d'accord ils disent que les
attaches musculaires sont effectivement
relativement faiblarde pour lui
permettre de nage et ça c'est pareil je
suis relativement d'accord
donc il conclut que ballack eux deux le
coût de spinosaures n'était pas fait
pour nager ceci étant dit il parle quand
même un peu plus loin des des basiliques
aider d'autres animaux qui ont la queue
bien aplati comme spinosaurus et qui
sont tout à fait capables de nager et
qui nagent d'ailleurs très très bien
même si là que joue un rôle assez
mineures alors peut-être que nizar
ibrahim trop insister sur le rôle de la
queue pour dire que spinosaurus était
aquatiques mais enfin on a tellement
d'autres preuves par ailleurs que
spinosaurus était aquatique et notamment
des analyses isotopiques qui montre
qu'il passait le plus clair de son temps
dans la flotte
que bof
il ya même il ya pas longtemps il ya un
spinosaurus des brésiliens ils ont
analysé ils ont fait des coupes
histologiques des membres et ils ont vu
que les membres étaient paquillo
statique ce qui veut dire que les
membres sont alourdies en fait les
jambes sont alourdies comme des ballasts
donc donc ça aussi ça va ce très fort
dans le sens d'un d'un mode de vie
semi-aquatique au moins semi-aquatique
voire fortement aquatique généralement
l'apa qui hostos des membres enfin je
veux dire on retrouve ça chez les
crocodiles chez les hippopotames on
parle quand même d'animaux qui passe le
plus clair de leur temps dans l'eau
venir pour que le pour que les eaux des
membres s'adapte à ce point là à la
flotte
il faut quand même que l'animal passe
très longtemps dans la flotte donc
encore une fois c'est c'est ce fameux
problème bas du du faux dilemme mêlée à
l'homme de paille c'est à dire que vous
mettez ce faux dilemme du ca où c'est un
dauphin ou sais rien ou c'est moi qui ai
raison
en gros donc où ces ados fans c'est moi
qui ai raison et et puis bien évidemment
vous avez juste à dire que bah oui mais
quand même les crocodiles ils ont aussi
les hop actuel statique ouais mais un
crocodile ces semi aquatique dont j'ai
raison c'est pour ça que je reviens à
dire bah oui mais ton truc il y avait
fait table
voilà là par exemple il dit voilà les
crocodiles sont d excellents nageurs
comparé aux espèces terrestres mais ils
ne nagent pas assez vite pour rattraper
des poisons pour attraper des poissons
donc même si spinosaures in un jeu aussi
bien qu'un crocodile bas j'ai raison
c'est pas un aquatique à tantie
spinosaures leininger aussi bien qu'un
crocodile nizar ibrahim il a quand même
le droit de dire que spinosaures étaient
majoritairement aquatique où on va aussi
contesté le fait que les crocodiles sont
majoritairement aquatique je veux dire
la plus le plus clair du temps que les
crocodiles passe sur terre c'est à ne
rien faire il reste allongé c'est tout
je veux dire c'est pas des trucs qui
sont habitués à se mouvoir sur terre
même s'il passe du temps sur terre donc
sa fille donc en fait ça ça rend cette
hypothèse complètement irréfutables
l'hypothèse le wedding modèle c'est
complètement irréfutables à partir du
moment où un animal qui n'est pas un
dauphin ben voilà c'est bon c'est c'est
moi qui ai raison c'est exactement ça
donc là ouais j'ai laissé 1
petit commentaire qui rappelle les mots
exacts d'ibrahim son spinosaurus devait
être un prédateur aquatique actif et
très spécialisés qui poursuivaient et
attraper ces trois dans la colonne d'eau
et à côté de ça il nous dit le ils nous
disent les crocodiles sont plutôt des
chasseurs en embûches et pas vraiment d
poursuiveurs donc spinosaurus n'était
pas à poursuivre heures hier en corse
ce flou dilemme devait spinosaures il
était quand même
nizar ibrahim ce qu'il a dit c'est
qu'ils étaient capables d'attraper les
proies dans la colonne d'eau est ce que
les chasseurs en embûches sont capables
d'attraper les proies dans la colonne
d'eau oui est ce qu une embûche c'est
pas une poursuite sur une traite à
courte distance
si donc il était capable de poursuivre
et d'attraper des proies dans la colonne
d'eau oui en tout cas les crocodiles en
sont capables donc si spinosaures si
spinosaurus est raisonnablement
comparable à un crocodile ce qu'ils
n'arrêtent pas de faire depuis tout à
l'heure
est ce que nizar ibrahima faye ne valide
absolument pas l'hypothèse de nizar
ibrahim
maintenant il attaque les membres donc
il rappelle que le fémur est plutôt
petit ce qui est une bonne remarque que
le fémur est effectivement petit c'est
l'un des arguments qui soutiennent que
justement mais les membres postérieurs
été réduits ce qui va de pair dans
généralement avec un mode de vie
aquatique
mais il va pas s'arrêter là dessus ça il
va pas en parler ce qui va s'ils en ont
parlé sait par contre c'est les
phalanges ou qui va en parler des
phalanges parce que vous rappelez ils
ont fait une super analyse qui sert à
rien ce que vous vous rappelez sanaria
montré chez les oiseaux principe
d'actual isme si vous n'avez déjà rien
démontré avec la forme des phalanges
chez les oiseaux
qu'espérez-vous démontré chez les
dinosaures à leur compte alors qu'on est
sensé ne rien connaître de leur écologie
ou que ce qu'on connaît de leur écologie
n'est que reconstruit y aurait juste
fallu cité nizar ibrahim au moment où il
dit vous avez vu cette phalange ça veut
dire qu'il y avait une panne mur et il
fallait citer l'article sur les oiseaux
vous avez vu les phalanges des oiseaux
ça n'a rien à voir avec la palme mur et
puis voilà basta quoi y'a pas moi faire
une discussion comme ça une analyse
statistique
et puis je suis un peu mauvaise foi vous
voyez quand même la réduction des
membres postérieurs indique
potentiellement qu' il était aquatique
spinosaurus mais par contre ils
pouvaient pas chasser les proies sous
l'eau et donc il n'était pas un
poursuite prédateurs oui d'accord les
preuves indiquent que que j'ai tort mais
j'ai raison quand même j'ai raison quand
même voix les mages et parce que j'ai
posé cette hypothèse à la con que
c'était près poursuit de prédation
poursuite prédation voilà et puis cette
hypothèse étant irréfutables et ben
voila hop c'est tout c'est pas donc vous
pourrez accumulés et à chaque fois la
conclusion de ces paragraphes c'est ça à
chaque fois là chaque paragraphe est
construit un peu de la même façon c'est
ils font la liste de toutes les preuves
qui vont dans le sens de d'un mode de
vie aquatique et à la fin ils disent
c'est très cohérent avec le modèle est
rond parce que le modèle est rond je
vous le rappelle recouvre à peu près
tous les modes de vie semi-aquatique
existants mais ça ne l'est pas avec le
modèle qui fait de spinosaures à dauphin
donc il explique très bien que
spinosaures était un nageur rapide très
bien mais ça n'a jamais été l'hypothèse
de nizar ibrahim quoi ensuite on nous
parle de la voilure dorsale comment la
voilure dorsale atterri dans la
discussion sur le sur l'adaptation au
milieu aquatique et bien selon eux c'est
ce qui est surligné dans ce paragraphe
ici la voilure dorsale aurait fait une
traînée tellement gigantesque donc c'est
ce qui est écrit ici a dit drague le
drague c'est la cedh a traîné donc cette
traînée aurait limité l'accélération de
spinosaures et donc ils n'auraient pas
pu nager
en tout cas il n'aurait pas pu nager
vite ce que tout ce qu'ils veulent
démontrer c'est que spinosaures ne
n'agit pas vite et qu'ils pouvaient pas
attraper les poissons donc leurs
arguments c'est que la voilure dorsale
empêcher la nage rapide
sauf que je vous défie dans ce
paragraphe de trouver la moindre
référence à la moindre analyse
hydrodynamique relatives à spinosaurus
vous n'en trouverez pas le seul truc qui
est cité s'est une fois de plus ibrahim
et il n'a pas fait ce genre de l'analyse
phase i du coup il a fait une analyse de
l'hydrodynamisme de la queue à la limite
donc lui au moins il s'était fait chier
à au moins un peu à faire un petit
modèle en plastoc à passer dans l'autre
voilà vous auriez plus au moins faire la
même chose quoi vous auriez pu au moins
faire une analyse de l'hydrodynamisme
avant de faire des affirmations comme ça
avant de faire des affirmations sur le
fait que la voilure dorsale allait créer
une traînée etc etc
parce que là c'est une affirmation mais
totalement gratos un ya pâle il n'y a
pas la moindre référence à quoi que ce
soit là dedans
il ne cite même pas d'autres études qui
ont étudié d'autres animaux avec des
voilures dorsale comme par exemple les
espadons et qui ont montré que la
voilure dorsale avait une traînée
gigantesque par exemple non qu'il ne le
cite pas il ne cite rien du tout c'est
juste une hypothèse haddock 2e pour eux
rien à cirer
on en est là on en est là et en dessous
ils nous disent que donc les les
vertèbres de spinosaures avait décapité
pneumatiques et que cette gelée mathy
cité aurait empêché spinosaures de nager
avant de nous dire que les manchots
eux-mêmes son pneumatique juste ici
voilà penguins art pas qui est aux tic
batlak mésozoïque théropodes are also
know matic les manchots sont de très
bons nageurs ils sont pas qu'ils
haussent totti c'est à dire qu'ils ont
les eaux épais comme je voulais dit tout
à l'heure pour le spinosaures et ils
sont aussi pneumatiques
donc ils le sont moins que le
spinosaures parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
qualité pneumatiques dans les vertèbres
mais ils sont aussi pneumatiques et
comme je l ai dit tout à l'heure
spinosaures il avait enfin les
spinosaures idée avait très probablement
les aux pâquis au sto tic donc les
autres est lourd pour agir comme des
balles à ce qui devrait compenser comme
chez les manchots
c'est cette automatisation alors ça
devait certainement beaucoup moins
le compenser puisque les manchots non
pas des diverticules de leurs de leurs
poumons de leurs sacs aérien ne vont pas
jusque dans les vertèbres chez les
manchots
donc il donc spinosaures devait quand
même avoir une meilleure flottabilité
qu'un manchot mais il avait des
adaptations en milieu aquatique il avait
des eaux qui agissaient comme des
ballasts des opa qui est aux tic comme
les manchots qui compensaient leur de
matisse it et là il nous sort des d'une
étude de henderson étape donc c'est
quand même source m et il nous sort des
calculs fin des valeurs de densité du
corps alors ses valeurs de densité du
corps sont forcément un moment ou un
autre
adapté de calcul de masse corporelle je
vous renvoie mer vers ma vidéo une fois
de plus sur les calculs de masse
corporelle chez les dinosaures et à quel
point on peut s'en servir
ces voix là c'est cadeau je vais pas
trop m'attarder dessus et pour finir sur
la crête
il nous dit que la crête de spinosaures
devait si elle avait été exposée à la
surface en gros on aurait été entraîné
par les courants et tout ça est donc que
spinoza aurait dû nager en a une
certaine profondeur de qu'il estime à
plus de 6 mètres comme ça c'est donc ça
voilà six mètres de profondeur au moins
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir nager
confortablement
bon c'est ignorer l'existence des
canards je veux dire les canaris neige à
la surface pourtant et ça va ils sont
pas mort je veux dire ce serait marrant
justement c'est si effectivement
spinosaures avait les pieds palmés et
qu'il avait justement tous nos bateaux
fort dans ses vertèbres mais les pieds
relativement lourds sont était marrant
que spinosaures nage comme un canard ça
aurait pu être drôle mais encore une
fois ce n'est pas d'hypothèses que
soi-disant d'ibrahim selon laquelle
spinosaures était un nageur et qu'ils
devaient nager comme comme à settat
c'est donc une fois de plus ça veut dire
que ibrahim avait tort alors que ce que
ibrahim a dit c'est que spinosaures
étaient majoritairement aquatique et que
s'il vivait comme un canard basse ça va
globalement avec je qualifie brahim même
si c'était peut-être parce qu'ils
imaginaient un mais ça va globalement
avec ce qu'il a écrit dans son article
de 2014
et c'est tout ce qui compte ce qu'il a
pu dire à côté dans des conférences et
tout ça ça compte pas ce qui compte
c'est ce qui est
oublié dans la les articles sur lequel
il ya son nom il re attaque sur la même
rengaine spinosaurus pouvait pas nager
vite
et alors ce qui rajoute cette fois c'est
que spinosaurus pouvait pas nager vite
mais en plus il n'y avait pas de
poissons qui nagent est lentement au
caire m
alors ça c'est là ça c'est l'affirmation
gratuite mais complètement gratos je
veux dire qui a calculé la vitesse des
poissons qui vivaient dans les quelques
[Rires]
mg a calculé la vitesse donc aux prises
six décès la quand devenir des proies
potentielles de spinosaures et voilà la
fameuse phrase le modèle est rond ne
nécessite pas que spinosaures puisse
nager pour être soutenu mais il n'est
pas contredit non plus par la
possibilité que spinosaures sache nager
donc si tu arrives à démontrer que
spinosaures ne savait pas nager
le modèle héron est vrai si tu arrives à
démontrer que spinoza savait nager
le modèle héron est vrai
ton modèle est irréfutable merci basta
si vous n'étiez pas encore parti
maintenant vous pouvez partir
l'article est finie l'article est fini
voilà il vient de le déclarer si
spinosaures nages
j'ai raison si spinosaures nage pas je
raison quand même voilà et c'est tout
dans celle inverse d'ailleurs si
spinosaures nash pages les raisons ci
spinosaures nage j'ai raison quand même
fin du couple est générique vous pouvez
remballer ensuite il parle de la voilure
dorsaz il essaye de trouver sa fonction
enfin les discute de sa fonction et tout
ça pour conclure que c'est du sexuel
voilà c'est un rôle pour la parade
sexuelle sans vraiment apporter de
nouveaux arguments que les espèces qui
vivent aujourd'hui qui ont une voix leur
dorsale généralement s'en servent pour
comme caractère sexuel ceci étant dit si
vous regardez le basilic par exemple
c'est un s'est très fortement dit morphx
c'est à dire que les femelles n'ont pas
cette crête sur le dos donc il va
falloir trouver beaucoup plus de
matériel de spinosaures des mâles et des
femelles avant de pouvoir dire que cette
hypothèse est vrai ou pas donc en gros
c'est une hypothèse qui pour l'instant
n'est pas démontrée n'est pas
démontrable
enfin sera démontrable dans un futur
très très très lointain parce qu'il est
non seulement faire trouver suffisamment
de spinosaurus complet pour pouvoir voir
qu'il y en a certains qui ont une crête
est certain qu'ils en ont pas mais en
plus il va falloir le temps que les gens
se chamaillent en se disant est ce que
c'est des mâles et des femelles ou pas
ou est ce que ces deux espèces
différentes
et là où c'est intéressant c'est que il
parle du basilic justement et en
précisant que le basilic nage très bien
voilà même si ça que n'est pas hyper
utile au processus
mais quelle voix lasse et enfin que ça
que similaire à spinosaurus n'est pas
hyper utile au processus
elle est là quand même donc lui nage
très bien et puis il nous parle d'un il
nous parle ensuite d'être épanouie des
et de dollars bronze au russe donc enfin
d'être des panneaux au rider comme il
put rhône hector et dollars aux russes
qui ont aussi une voile sur la queue et
qui sont interprétés comme comme étant
arboricole ceci étant dit il mentionne
quand même que de la bronze au russe a
été interprétée comme étant comme étant
un nageur et ça c'est intéressant à
souligner c'est que spinosaurus on le
connaît depuis les années
30 je crois mais si on n'avait pas connu
depuis les années 30 si le premier
fossile qu'on avait découvert ça avait
été celui de nizar ibrahim c'est à dire
que si le premier fossile de spinosaurus
conte à s'arrêter en 2020 voilà les
pattes arrière relativement réduite et
là que relativement plate est très
flexible
qu'est-ce qu'on aurait conclu on
n'aurait rien conclut d'autre qu' il est
aquatique
parce que les jambes réduite et la queue
plate comme ça à part animal aquatique
je vois pas ce que c'est et c'est juste
parce que c'est spinosaurus qui a un
débat en réalité mais si vous revenez au
truc de base
si on avait découvert les fossiles de
nizar ibrahim directement sans tout le
reste avant on aurait conclu que
spinosaurus il était aquatique
directement et c'est pareil pour de la
bronze au russe il a fallu découvrir des
baux fossiles pour avant de démontrer il
a fallu faire des analyses de ta faut il
a fallu faire beaucoup beaucoup
d'analysés avant d'arriver y a pas fallu
juste tremper son doigt là comme ils
font au vent pour et puis faire une
revue de la littérature des arguments
qui m'arrange pour pour arriver à
démontrer
le mode de vie de la bronze au russe qui
n'est pas démontré d'ailleurs si ça se
trouve il est vraiment aquatique de la
bourse russe
c'est juste parce qu'elle aiderait pas
nos idées en général sont sont
interprétés comme étant à arboricole que
je veux bien croire qu'il ait pas qui
n'est pas nageurs mais enfin je veux
dire
dans l'absolu c'est une espèce éteinte
ans ne sait pas comment elle se l'était
son vrai mode de vie donc voila voila je
veux dire je suis désolé mais celui qui
a d'hypothèses nul donc l'hypothèse nul
c'est pas lui une hypothèse qui est
nulle l'hypothèse nul c'est l'hypothèse
de base en anglais on appelle ça une
hypothèse nul donc l'hypothèse de base
selon moi c'est quand même plus que
spinosaurus était aquatique parce que
les plus beaux fossiles qu'on a de
spinosaurus ils nous disent aquatique et
après il faut démontrer le contraire
mais peut démontrer le contraire ça veut
pas dire comme je disais faire du chili
picking comme ça et aller chercher les
preuves là où je me cale soit voilà
encore hélas il est à chaque fois ce qui
est marrant c'est dans ce paragraphe c
qui nous déballe les exemples de trucs
qui ont une crête comme spinosaurus pour
nous dire que spinosaurus savait pas
nager
sauf que une fois de plus cela il nous
sort le triton le triton qui sait nager
et ensuite il nous dit à mes les
crocodiles
ils ont aussi une queue aplatit mais ils
s'en servent aussi pour la soulève afin
d'impressionner les autres mâles et
pendant les la parade amoureuse baril
mais les crocodiles savent aussi nager
donc on n'exclut pas du tout la
possibilité que spinosaurus se soit
servi de sa queue et pour le
la parade et pour nager quoi pas du tout
en tout cas c'est ce que le principe
d'un dualisme nous nous dit ici et c'est
ce qui dit tout à fait leur les deux
potel les deux hypothèses ne sont pas du
tout exclusive donc mutuellement
exclusives ne s'excluent pas
mutuellement
ensuite il passe au régime alimentaire
ce qu'il appelle les environnementale
factors donc il revient sur l'étude de
romain amiot qu'ils disaient d'après les
isotopes que spinosaures était
principalement un passé principalement
son temps dans l'eau et il ya une autre
analyse isotopique qui montrait que il
mangeait essentiellement du poisson donc
il prend les résultats de ces études
et puis les retours dans dix ans que oui
mais ces résultats quand même ils
indiquent qu'ils passent essentiellement
son temps dans l'eau mais pas que et qu'
ils mangeaient essentiellement du
poisson mais pas que donc ça veut dire
que j'ai raison
d'ailleurs on le voit bien les
crocodiles les crocodiles
ils passent leur temps entre l'eau et la
terre donc spinosaures n'était pas
aquatique
voilà donc les crocodiles donc
spinosaures a exactement la même
signature isotopique les que les
crocodiles non je dis ça mais j'en sais
rien mais je veux dire en gros la
signature isotopique indique que
spinosaures se comportait exactement
comme un crocodile c'est à dire qu'ils
passaient essentiellement son temps dans
l'eau mais pas que donc il passe pas son
temps essentiellement dans l'eau c'est
ce genre j'ai pris les résultats des
études et je les ai retourné comme des
chaussettes juste pour moi juste pour
moi quoi donc on va vous voyez les
résultats de ces études
on va les ignorer enfin on va pas les
ignorer on va carrément les retourner
pour en faire des résultats qui nous
arrange banon s'ils disent qu'ils
passent essentiellement son temps dans
donc un temps considérable dans l'eau
distillée de manière similaire un
crocodile je suis et qu'en plus après tu
te permet une comparaison avec les
crocodiles
bah tu dis pas ensuite que spinosaures
ne passait pas le plus clair de son
temps dans la flotte contrairement à ce
que nizar ibrahim a dit nizar ibrahim il
a dit il passe le plus clair de son
temps dans la flotte le comparant très
clairement un crocodile donc
voilà la mauvaise foi la mauvaise foi et
on arrive enfin en résumé donc un la fin
voyez le générique de fin est là c'est
bon on arrive aux bouffes on arrive au
bout on a gagné on a gagné donc le
résumé il y a plein de preuve que j'ai
raison et aucun arguments possibles ne
viendra contredire le modèle est rond
mon modèle est tiré de conclusion mon
modèle est irréfutable c'est la
conclusion mon modèle est irréfutable
aucun argument ne vient contredire le
modèle est rond et vous voulez pas me
croire qu'il est vraiment en train de
dire qu'il ya aucun argument qui peut
réfuter son hypothèse est bien bien
voire même les preuves que spinosaures
était un très bon nageur
voilà la déclaration de fall le mot de
la fin de ceux de cet article c'est vous
savez pourquoi j'ai raison parce que de
toute façon mon hypothèse est
irréfutable vous pourrez montrer autant
de fois que vous voulez que spinosaures
y nager comme comme un dieu de toute
façon moi j'ai décidé qu'il était comme
un héros et puis alors à la fin il s'en
est même plus pour dire pour utiliser le
conditionnel voilà en tant que possibles
prédateurs aquatiques de poursuites pour
tout prédateur spinosaures a des
problèmes d'instabilité dans l'eau
notamment la la traîner la traînée très
forte
il a pas à ce conditionnel va te faire
[ __ ] à la moi j'ai décrété que sans
aucune parce que c'était là qu'il avait
pas mis de référence c'était sur cette
affirmation la maj est décrété que sans
aucune référence en sans citer aucun
expert d'hydrodynamique au monde j'ai
décrété que spinosaures il savait pas
nager
allez vous faire voir voilà donc c'était
l'article
encensé par la critique l'article qui
enfin démontrer que nizar ibrahim dit
n'importe quoi
et ben non et ben non c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe cet article voilà si
vous êtes venu chercher de la bonne
science c'est pas dans cet article que
vous en trouvez il n'y a ici que
déception
il n'y a ici que la mort il n'y a ici
que la tromperie et puis bah si vous
étiez
comme j'ai dit si vous êtes et éthicien
vous avez surtout le mans reconnu tout
un tas de sophismes je vous en ai planté
quelques uns il y en a beaucoup d'autres
et si vous voulez les voir eh bien allez
lire cet article vous allez voir c'est
très marrant voilà c'était paléo news je
vous remercie d'avoir suivi n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens et je vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]